ALL RIGHT AINSLEY: YEAH, THANK
YOU, STEVE LET’S BRING IN KARL
ROVE FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR SERVED
AS SENIOR ADVISOR DEPUTY CHIEF
OF STAFF TO PRESIDENT GEORGE W.
BUSH.
YOU SEE ALL THOSE PICTURES,KARL.
WHAT COMES TO BEHIND?
>> WELL I WAS HONORED WHEN I
SERVED IN THE WHITE HOUSE TO
ATTEND THE CEREMONY EACH DAY AT
ARLINGTON AND IT’S ONE OF THE
MOST MOVING MOMENTS YOU
COULD EVER IMAGINE AND I CAN’T
BEGIN TODAY WITHOUT THINKING OF
THE MANY FAMILIES I MET DURING
MY NEARLY SEVEN YEARS OF THE
WHITE HOUSE WHO HAD GIVEN
THEIR OWN TO SERVE OUR COUNTRY
AND GOD BLESS OUR COUNTRY, GOD
BLESS WHO DON THE UNIFORM OF OUR
COUNTRY AND THE FAMILIES THAT
SUPPORT THEM SO IT’S A
REMARKABLE DAY TO REMEMBER SO
MANY PEOPLE.
PETE: YOU WERE ON THAT JOB AT A
TIME OF WAR WHICH ADDS SO MUCH
MORE WEIGHT TO IT AS WELL YOU’RE
A PATRIOT.
WE’RE ALSO TALKING ABOUT THE
REOPENING OF OUR COUNTRY AS
WE FACE COVID-19 AND THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICE
SECRETARY ALEX AZAR WAS TALKING
ABOUT REOPENING AND HOW WE DO IT
>> THANKS TO PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND OUR GOVERNOR’S HISTORIC
RESPONSE TO THIS WE HAVE TO AND
WE CAN GET BACK TO WORK TO
SCHOOL, TO COMMUNITY, TO
ENGAGEMENT, BECAUSE IT’S NOT AN
ISSUE OF HEALTH VERSUS OUR
ECONOMY.
IT’S ACTUALLY AN ISSUE OF HEALTH
VERSUS HEALTH, BY BEING LOCKED
UP IN OUR HOMES, THERE’S VERY
REAL HEALTH CONSEQUENCES.
WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
FEWER CANCER SCREENINGS AND
TREATMENTS GOING ON.
WE HAVE LESS PREVENTIVE SERVICES
THOSE ARE REAL, DISCERNIBLE,
IMMEDIATE HEALTH CONSEQUENCES
THAT HAVE TO BE CONSIDERED JUST
AS MUCH AS THE SPREAD OF THIS
DISEASE HAS TO BE
CONSIDERED.
PETE:KARL, THE PRESIDENT SAID
MANY TIMES THE CURE CAN’T BE
WORSE THAN THE VIRUS.
ARE WE AT A POINT IN THE
LOCKDOWN ESPECIALLY IN THE
DEMOCRATIC STATES WHERE IT’S
GOING ON AND ON INDEFINITELY IS
IT JUST MAKING THE PROBLEM WORSE
>> WELL I THOUGHT SECRETARY AZA
R MADE A POWERFUL
POINT.
I SAW A CHART LAST WEEK OF THE
DECLINE IN THE SO-CALLED
ELECTIVE PROCEDURES.
18% FEWER CANCER TREATMENTS.
THINK ABOUT THAT FOR A MOMENT.
YES, WE OUGHT TO BE CONCERNED
ABOUT COVID-19.
WE’VE GOT TO TAKE PRECAUTIONS.
WE’VE GOT TO WEAR MASKS AND BE E
GAUGED ENGAGED IN SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND WE HAVE TO RETURN
OUR COUNTRY TO A PLACE WHERE WE
GO BACK TO WORK WHERE PEOPLE ARE
ABLE TO GO TO SEE THEIR DOCTOR,
WHERE THEY GO TO SEE WHERE THEY
GO GET PROCEDURES THAT THEY NEED
, AND WHERE WE BEGIN TO
RESTORE THE ABILITY OF FAMILIES
TO TAKE CARE OF THEMSELVES AND
PROVIDE FOR THEIR FUTURE, AND I
THOUGHT THE SECRETARY DID AN
EXCELLENT JOB OF POINTING OUT
THAT IF WE’RE SMART ABOUT IT AND
WE PRACTICE SAFE PRACTICE, THAT
WE CAN BEGIN TO RETURN THE
COUNTRY TO AS CLOSE TO
NORMAL AS COVID-19 IS GOING TO
ALLOW US TO DO SO.
STEVE: OF COURSE KARL, YOU’RE
THERE IN AUSTIN TEXAS AND
GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT TWEETED
THIS OUT ABOUT THE REOPENING IN
YOUR STATE.
TEXAS IS REOPENING SAFE, SMART
AND STRONG WHICH PROMPTED FORMER
CONGRESSMAN  BETO O’ROURKE TO
RESPOND TO THE GOVERNOR WITH
THIS ONE.
DANGERU DUMB, AND WEAK.
THE PANDEMIC IS VERY POLITICAL
NOW, ISN’T IT?
>> YEAH, AT FIRST I WAS A
LITTLE CONFUSED I THOUGHT HE
MIGHT BE TWEETING OUT HIS OWN
PERSONAL MOTTO.
LOOK LET’S TALK ABOUT TEXAS JUST
FOR A SECOND.
THE NUMBER OF CASES AND DEATHS
ARE TRENDING DOWN.
THE DEATHS PER CAPITA IN TEXAS
ARE AMONG THE LOWEST IN THE
UNITED STATES.
WE’RE THE SECOND-MOST POPULOUS
STATE WITH 29 MILLION PEOPLE AND
WE HAVE ONE OF THE LOWEST PER
CAPITA DEATH RATES IN THE
COUNTRY.
HOSPITALIZATIONS ARE STEADY WE
HAVE 1,572 PEOPLE IN OUR
HOSPITALS AND WITH THOUSANDS,
THOUSANDS OF AVAILABLE BEDS, SO
WE’RE DOING A GOOD JOB OF
MONITORING OF DOING THIS.
OUR BED CAPACITY IS ENORMOUS.
OUR TESTING CONTINUES TO RAMP UP
WE HAVE TESTED 88 6,000 PEOPLE
AS OF SUNDAY, EXCUSE ME, AS OF
SATURDAY OUT OF 29 MILLION.
THAT MEANS ONE OUT OF EVERY 33
TEXANS HAS ALREADY BEEN TESTED
AND NUMBERS CONTINUE TO GO UP.
NOW WHAT DOES THAT REALLY MEAN?
LET ME GIVE YOU A COMPARISON AND
I DON’T MEAN TO PICK ON
PENNSYLVANIA BUT ITS GOT LESS
THAN HALF THE PEOPLE IN TEXAS.
WE HAVE 56,000 CASES IN TEXAS.
WE’VE HAD 1,533 DEATHS,
UNFORTUNATELY.
GOD BLESS EACH AND EVERY ONE OF
THEM.
13 PEOPLE ON SUNDAY.
PENNSYLVANIA, WHICH IS LOCKED
DOWN AND LOCKED DOWN AND LOCKED
DOWN HAS 71, 656 CASES, DESPITE
THE FACT IT’S LESS THAN HALF THE
POPULATION OF TEXAS.
5,145 DEATHS AND 28 PEOPLE ON
SUNDAY.
SO LOOK, WE’RE IN TEXAS,
GOVERNOR ABOUT ABBOTT IS RIGHT
WE’RE TREATING IT SAFE, SMART
AND STRONG AND I THOUGHT IT WAS
A CHEAP SHOT BY ROBERT FRANCIS
O’ROURKE TO TAKE AFTER THE
GOVERNOR AND IN HIS MESSAGE
HE SAID STAY HOME IF YOU CAN AND
WEAR A MASK.
GUESS WHAT THAT’S EXACTLY THE
MESSAGE OF OUR GOVERNOR.
IF YOU DON’T NEED TO GO OUT
STAY-AT-HOME AND WHENEVER YOU GO
OUT, WHEN YOU GO TO WORK, TO THE
STORE, MOVE AROUND THE COMMUNITY
WEAR A MASK AND MAINTAIN SOCIAL
DISTANCING, BUT YOU KNOW, MR.
O’ROURKE LOST A RACE FOR THE
SENATE.
HE JUST DEVASTATED HIMSELF IN A
RACE FOR THE UNITED STATES
PRESIDENCY.
MY SENSE IS HE’S GETTING READY
TO RUN FOR GOVERNOR IN A COUPLE
YEARS SO HE’S TAKING CHEAP SHOTS
WHENEVER AND WHEREVER HE CAN.
I’D SAY BE SAFE, SMART, AND
STRONG AND STOP SAYING DANGEROUS
, DUMB AND WEAK THINGS.
AINSLEY: WELL, AS JOE BIDEN IS
DEFENDING HIS COMMENTS OR
FACING A LOT OF BACKLASH ABOUT
THE COMMENTS ON BLACK VOTERS YOU
HAVE ELIZABETH WARREN WHO SAYS
SHE’S GOING TO HOST A HIGH-
DOLLARS FUNDRAISER FOR
BIDEN BUT WHO CAN FORGET
WHAT SHE SAID LAST YEAR OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> BILLIONAIRES IN WINE CAVES
SHOULD NOT PICK THE NEXT
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
NO TO THE BILLIONAIRES.
NO TO THE BILLIONAIRES WHETHER
THEY ARE SELF-FUNDING OR
WHETHER THEY ARE FUNDING, WE
ARE THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND
THAT’S THE PARTY OF THE PEOPLE.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> GET RID OF SECRET SPENDING
BY THE BILLIONAIRES.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> AND BREAK THE BIG DONOR
STRANGLE HOLD.
AINSLEY: KARL, WHAT’S YOUR
REACTION?
>> WELL LET’S BE HONEST SHE
DIDN’T MEAN IT WHEN SHE SAID
THOSE THINGS AFTER ALL SHE RUN
FOR THE U.S. SENATE A COUPLE
YEARS BEFORE MASSACHUSETTS, HAD
BIG DOLLAR FUNDRAISERS, HAD
RAISED MONEY FROM PEOPLE WHO HAD
PACK, TOOK THAT MONEY AND
TRANSFERRED INTO HER
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN WHERE SHE
WAS MAKING THESE PROCLAMATIONS
OF CAMPAIGN PURITY AND THEN SHE
STARTED HER, OR   ALLOWED TO
HAVE START AND DEFENDED HAVING
HER OWN SUPER PACK SO SHE DIDN’T
MEAN THOSE THINGS.
WE SHOULD NOTE THAT ELIZABETH
WARREN IS WILLING TO SAY ONE
THING AND DO ANOTHER, AND SO
WE’RE GOING TO SEE IT.
NOW LOOK, LET’S HAVE A LIST OF
ALL OF THE BIG DONORS ON WHO ARE
ON THE ELIZABETH WARREN
FUNDRAISER FOR JOE BIDEN.
INTRANS LET US KNOW THERE ARE
BILLIONAIRES OR  MILLIONAIRES
AMONG THEM SO WE CAN JUDGE
WHETHER OR  NOT SHE MEANT WHAT
SHE SAID WHEN SHE SAID THOSE
THINGS EARLIER.
I’LL TELL YOU IT’S INTERESTING
TO ME I DON’T KNOW WHETHER THE
BIDEN CAMPAIGN PUT IT OUT OR
ELIZABETH WARREN PUT IT OUT BUT
LAST WEEK I THOUGHT IT WAS
INTERESTING THAT SOMEBODY SAID
OH, ELIZABETH WARREN AND JOE
BIDEN TALK EVERY WEEK.
WE’VE ALREADY SEEN HIM BEGIN TO
TRIM HIS SALES AND MOVE LEFT.
HE’S ENDORSED, YOU KNOW, NOT
MEDICARE FOR ALL BUT MOVING
TOWARDS MEDICARE FOR ALL, AND HE
EXPLICITLY SAID YOU KNOW,
ELIZABETH WITH HER CRITICISMS OF
WHAT I DID ON THAT 2005
BANKRUPTCY BILL, SHE WAS
RIGHT, AND I WOULD, IF I COULD
BECOME PRESIDENT I’M GOING TO
ACT ON HER RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT
UNDOING WHAT I DID IN 2005.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS AN
INTERESTING MOVE.
PETE: ABSOLUTELY WELL KARL ROVE
YOU WERE THE ARCHITECT OF TWO
SUCCESSFUL RUNS FOR THE WHITE
HOUSE YET YOU KNOW WHAT YOU’RE
TALKING ABOUT.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME ON THIS
MEMORIAL DAY WEEKEND THANK
YOU, SIR.
>> AND PETE, I’D BE REMISS IF I
DIDN’T SAY I’M GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
SERVICE TO OUR DIFFERENT ARE GOD